Keanu Reeves just a national treasure at
this point / kidding there should be a
statue of him in DC says yeah I think
I'm back negative
[Music]
John wick Chapter two so John Luke
chapter 2 is the sequel to the
surprisingly entertaining John wick here
in that movie that no one thought was
going to be good we saw Burrell it was
actually really good and John liked
Chapter two we can't really get too much
into the plot without I want you to kind
of experience it point is twists and
turns and murder and now we have John
wick to first of all what I love about
this is Keanu Reeves I'm pretty sure
Keanu Reeves is the only one who could
make this franchise work even the cheesy
ass dialogue in here Keanu Reeves
commits and makes it work I go he's like
I'm going to kill them I'm going to kill
them all I'm like Keanu let's get
through it and I enjoyed the
world-building this movie feels like it
slows down more than John wick one day
and that I feel like John wick one is
more exciting or maybe just the fact
that John wick one was just more
surprising than John wick to like going
in John wick one you didn't know what to
expect now we have the bar set we know
what to expect with John wick too and
anytime it kind of takes a dipper like
oh wait it's not as exciting as John
wick one however the world you saw in
John wick one you know what the hotel is
kind of a safe haven whatever you have
against someone when you're in there
it's like holy ground and hi-lander no
one fights that this takes that lord
really expands the mythology to a few
more rules you didn't know about that
are in this world I thought that was
really cool man world building is
important for a sequel to do the sequel
doesn't and the action the action is
going down like John wick wanna jizz dem
exciter John wick is the boogeyman
precision personified in human form
never misses if he misses the head
that's because he shot you in the chest
twice or took out your knees before he
shot you in the head everyone coming
after John wick has the aim of
stormtroopers so for John wick it's just
fish in a barrel man murder murder
murder murder people die but that is
when the action is going down the second
half is when the [ __ ] hits the fan more
than the first half for the first half
of this movie they really are in a tough
spot because John wick one had such a
pure motivation for John wick he's
[ __ ] bust knew his place and killed
his dog his dog which was the last link
he had to his now dead wife that will
bring an ex hitman out of retirement to
kill some folks
so in this movie they're kind of stuck
with what do we do to get John wick back
he kind of fulfilled that so they come
up with a plot device to bring him back
but just the motivation in it just isn't
Pierre is someone who wants revenge for
love so this movie really isn't a tough
spot where is the first action sequence
in the movie built off of the last movie
yeah but then that wraps up that is the
intro that's like before the beginning
title even comes on the screen now we
have a plot that really isn't linked to
the first movie so much but you have to
have a reason for him to come back so
the movie spends half the movie building
that reason up because you have to come
up with a whole new plot device guys in
the end John wick chapter two I enjoyed
I just don't know that John wick movie
can actually be as good as the first
movie because of the surprise factor
just when a movie comes out of nowhere
it hits you so hard with that surprise
there's no way for a sequel to follow
that up and be as good as it you know
the main plot some motivation in the
first movie I can get behind more than
the second movie but Keanu Reeves
delivers and shows that he is now and
probably forever will be John wick it's
a fun movie it's a ridiculous movie some
of the dialogue made sure like it only
Keanu could do that if you like John
wick one I think you'll like John wick
two of John with one wasn't your thing
this definitely is not going to be your
thing and I will say John wick chapter
two is a good time no alcohol required
there are some great hits like when John
wick is out of ammo and has to use
hand-to-hand or possibly pencils there
are some greats that happened to people
holy [ __ ] alright guys so John wick
chapter two have you seen it what did
you think about it or what do you think
is better John wick or John wick chapter
two I know this review is a bit early a
lot of you haven't seen it yet I'm just
saying after you see it come back and
let me know what you think this video
will be here for you whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]